shifting gears now as we celebrate Black
History Month we are very excited about
our next guest she's a Pioneer she's a
supermodel she's a badass she is Beverly
Johnson the fashion world icon broke
berries back in 1974 when she became the
first woman of color to Grace the cover
of American Vogue she is one of the most
influential figures in fashion and guess
what she is still walking the runway
five decades into her career you go
Beverly Johnson is featured in the new
BET documentary it's called I love this
title black and iconic style Gods hosted
by the one and only Billy Porter here's
a look
there's a reason she was named one of
the 20th Century's most influential
people in fashion it was huge and I
didn't know I was the first woman of
color on on the cover of World magazine
it wasn't until people were interviewing
me globally that you know how does it
feel to be the first black woman to
cover American program like I am
yes you are Beverly Johnson she joins us
in the studio Beverly welcome I was
surprised number one this documentary is
so good it made me so proud because it
touches on so many different things in
the black experience in Black fashion
but let's focus on you I was surprised
that you were surprised to know that you
were the first black person on the cover
of Vogue was it something you wanted to
be on yes in order to be the top model
in the world I needed that cover I had
covers all over the world but I needed
that American Vogue cover to become the
top model in the world
so that is where my goals were is to be
the top line just a model but not a
black model
but did you think it was possible to be
on the cover Vogue
oh of course I thought it was possible
because I was doing covers of Vogue all
over the web were you encouraged the way
that we're told yes you can do this
uh yes and no Eileen Ford who is a
wonderful agent and the first woman that
ever saw yield power when I went to say
this is what I want I want a cosmetic
contract I want to write a beauty book
and I want the cover of American Vogue
it's then that I found out that there
had never been a black person undercover
Vogue magazine but she didn't say that
what did she say to you you will never
be on the cover of Vogue whoa
okay who do you think you are Cleopatra
and I'm thinking that's what she said to
you who do you think you are I'm
thinking to myself that's exactly who I
think I am because I knew to myself as a
little 20 year old because I knew I was
I wasn't going to get the cover with
Eileen Ford and that's why I changed
agency Eileen Ford is an amazing woman
yeah she was the first woman I saw yield
power and she had the number one agency
in the world modeling agency in the
world but Willamina models which was a
model of hers
you know to her modeling agency and
that's where I got I landed in college
and now people are using terms like
style God yes yeah what is it like to
hear that I think it's wonderful it's
what lizzo said it's about damn time yes
it's about during time and it's it's
really wonderful to be able to celebrate
our contribution to Fashion not only now
but through the years through the
decades through the centuries because
you know that's a part of our our
culture Our Heritage and we contribute
so much so thank you for doing this
interview and thank you bet
February 18th at eight o'clock
yes Beverly when did you know you were
pretty I'm always curious when I see
pretty girls because my grandmother told
me back in the day mother nature wasn't
as kind to you as she was because her
grandmother was wrong but well I mean
but I'm not even I'm not even mad about
it I mean so I didn't grow up thinking I
was a pretty girl when did you know that
you were pretty uh I didn't know I was
pretty until I went to college and some
I could make 75.00
being a fashion
at 75 there was no pretty in my family I
was in a competitive swimmer and I
wanted to go to college and that were my
those were my goals and nobody was
pretty and you're pretty it just started
modeling for financial reasons if you
could make exactly five an hour and your
dad was making 75 a week wow right
that's correct and you know there's a
long story how I got the piece of paper
to call the you know uh the the lady in
in New York and she's the one that got
me the appointment with Conde Nas and
then they came out my mother went
against my father's wishes and they came
out and said we want to take Beverly on
a trip for glamor magazine and it
happened just like there it goes Beverly
you came up with the Beverly Johnson
rule which calls on corporations and
fashion media beauty and cosmetics
Industries to ensure that 50 percent of
candidates interviewed for all open
market positions are people of all Races
are we succeeding on that rule no we're
not we haven't even budged at all and I
got that rule from the Rooney Rule in
the NFL and now you see the black
quarterbacks and we're really
participating they really are
participate in the NFL but we are not
seeing it in the industry because what
we need is we need a seat at the table
where the strategies are made in the
board of directors and we're not there
and we are participating in the forward
face the Ford fashion
ideals or not participating in the
economics of the fashion industry and
that's where I think that it needs to be
um we need to be inclusive how do you
describe your walk Beverly Johnson my
walk is I'm Beverly Johnson
[Laughter]
between
a runway model and a photographic model
right yes and so I just want to walk the
runway because I wanted to get to know
the designers and everything I was a
very curious young lady and so that's so
what happened was I started to walk the
runway and the runway models weren't
really happy about me coming over there
and their territory and then the the uh
fit models and runway models started to
do the covers in the magazines and
that's how that all happened can we just
say you are Beverly Johnson and you are
walking today in Dennis basso's fashion
yeah you're the closer and I'm closing
the show Dennis has great taste and
that's today thank you go Beverly you're
cheering you on always this documentary
is so good thank you so much nice to
have you here thank you it's called
Black and iconic style Gods it premieres
this Saturday at 8 o'clock on BET and
VH1 and like CBS we have to tell you
they're both part of the Paramount
Global family